here is an Oscar nominee for big a
wonderfully talented funny actor please
say hello to mr. Tom Hanks
Thank You Almighty captain of
showbusiness
just two weeks ago the Academy's Board
of Governors invited me to a full-tilt
bust out call the cops party at the
Century Plaza Hotel and it's a shame
they didn't invite you it may be all
glamour and glitter here at the Dorothy
Chandler Pavilion but you have not lived
until you have witnessed the Academy's
scientific and technical awards up close
in firsthand
Sylvester Stallone may be hollywood's
muscle and Geena Davis certainly has the
legs but these men and women are truly
the industry's backbone Bob Stoker's
nontoxic cobweb effects are miracle of
modern technology
Jim Doyle's dense low-hanging fog has
already revolutionized low-hanging fog
and believe me dr. Guido Carr Tony's
selectable and repeatable viscous drag
modules in hairy Baker's full fluid
action tripod heads make much better use
of the silk compound silicon than is on
display here this evening
I have lost the band
there was even one Oscar awarded two
weeks ago the Gordon East Sawyer award
it went to the Pioneer wizard who
created such seminal special effects as
these
for his work Ray Harryhausen was given a
standing ovation as best-selling author
Ray Bradbury presented him the award
thank you and particularly to the
Academy for this I'm most grateful and
honored and to the Board of Governors
for bestowing this upon me thank you so
very much
Oscar night is always an occasion to
remind audiences and ourselves that
movies are the result of the synergism
of art and science the Academy is proud
to honor all of those whose efforts
provide all of us with the joy of going
to the movies thank you
on hollywood's night of nights with
richard gere anjelica huston and shirley
maclaine